[موسيقى]
في اي لحظه قد تنطلق ويمكن ان تنفذ باشكال
مختلفه
تركيا على مدى الايام الماضيه في اشاره
الى العمليه البريه التي تهدد بتنفيذها
شماليه سوريه عمليه هدفها توسعه الحزام
الامني على طول الحدود الجنوبيه لتركيا
والقضاء التام على التنظيمات التي تعتبرها
تركيا ارهابيه وعلى راسها حزب العمال
الكردستاني وفرعه السوري وحداته وحمايه
الشعب التي تشكل العمود الفقري لما يعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في الافلام تتواصل
المشاورات مع الاطراف الفاعله وتحديدا
روسيا وامريكا اللتين تسعيان لاقناع تركيا
بالغاء العمليه التي تصر على القيام بها
فهل تمضي ان ترى في تنفيذ خطتها العسكريه
رغم الرفض الامريكي والروسي وما فرص
التوصل الى تفاهمات مع موسكو واشنطن
تستجيب لمخاوه في تركيا
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم حاله الترقب وهدوء حظر يا
سوداني حاليا المناطق الخادعه لسيطره ما
يعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مع استمرار
التعزيزات التركيه وارتفاع وتيره القصف
المكثف جوا وبرا على مناطق ومنشاته ومقر
هذه القوات في شمالي وشرقي سوريا عن ملامح
العمليه العسكريه التركيه المتوقعه
واحتمال اي تفاهم قد يلغيها او يؤجلها
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور علي بكير الخبير في
الشان التركي واستاذه العلاقات الدوليه في
مركز ابن خلدون بجامعه قطر منهم برج حسين
شلبي الكاتب والباحث في الشان الكردي ومن
نيورك العقيد نايلدز كبير الباحثين في
معهد نيولاينز للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه والمتحدث السابق باسم قوات
التحالف الدولي لمحاربه تنظيم الدوله
يوصل اذا الجيش التركي قصفه لمواقع حزب
العمال لكردستاني وفروعه في سوريا والعراق
بمختلف انواع الاسلحه تمهيدا للعمليه
الجديده شماليه سوريه رغم الدعوات
الامريكيه والروسيه الى ضبط النفس وخفض
التصعيد في هذا السياق كشف وزير الدفاع
التركيين خلال روسيا كار انا واشنطن طلبت
من انقره في عاده دراسه العمليه العسكريه
المحتمله وان انقره طلبت في المقابله
الوفاء بالتعهدات المقدمه اليها
[موسيقى]
كيف التصدي للتصميم التركي علشان عمليه
عسكريه بريه في شمال سوريا السؤال الصعب
الذي تلتقي فيه المتناقدات الى روسيا ولا
الولايات المتحده ولا الاكراد في الشمال
السوري لا احد يرغب في رؤيه قوات تركيا
تخترق الحدود مجددا لتحدث تغيرات في خريطه
السيطره الميدانيه في سوريا
جاءت لذلك المساعد دبلوماسيه الروسيه
حديثه لاقناع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بالانسحاب من مناطق تنتشر
فيها محاذيه للحدود التركيه ليس ما يطلبه
الروس جديده فثمت اتفاق توصلت اليه روسيا
وتركيا في صوت شيشارو اكتوبر من عام 2019
على اثر عمليه نبع السلام التي نفذتها
القوات التركيه في شمال سوريا
الاكراد مسافه 30 كم من الحدود السوريه
التركيه شرقيه الفرات ويمنح الاتفاق
الجانب التركيه سيطره مطلقه على الشريط
الحدودي بين مدينتي تل ابيض وراس العين
على طول مئه كيلو متر وعمق 30 كلم
وتلك هي المنطقه التي بسط عليها الاتراك
سيطرتهم خلال عمليه نبع السلام الان تعد
انقره عدتها لتحقيق ما نص عليه الاتفاق
ولم تلتزم به ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه
عمليه بريه جديده باتت على وشك ان تكون
امرا واقعه تستهدف بالاساس ثلاث مناطق في
الشمال السوري في مرحله اولى تريد تركيا
العسكري في ريف حلب وعشرات البلدات والقرى
المحيطه به اما المرحله الثانيه
لكن هذه الاهداف التركيه تصطدم بالاجننتين
المتناقتين لروسيا والولايات
المتحدهم لتحقيق مكاسبه جديده للنظام
السوري على حساب قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وادارتها الذاتيه في شمال شرق سوريا
اما الامريكيون فلهم وجود عسكري مهم في
المنطقه ضمن التحالف مع الاكراد لمواجهه
تنظيم الدوله حتى الان لم تجدي المساعد
دبلوماسيه الروسيه لاقناع وحدات ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه بالعوده للالتزام
باتفاق عام 2019
في الضغط على تركيا لمنع عمليه بريه قد
تاتي على مكاسب السيطره الميدانيه التي
تتمتع بها هذه الوحدات
وكما هو معروف فقد نفذت تركيا سابقا ثلاث
عمليات في الشمال السوري ضد وحدات حمايه
الشعب المدعومه يا ملكيا جرت اول عمليه
عسكريه تركيه في سوريا تحت عنوان درع
الفرات واستمرت قرابه سبعه اشهر وانتهت في
مارس اذار 2017
وسيطرت خلالها المعارضه السوريه بدعم تركي
على اعزاز وشرابلس ومدينه الباب بيري في
حلب الشرقي اما العمليه العسكريه الثانيه
فكانت تحت عنوان غصن الزيتون بدات في 2018
واستمرت اربعه اشهر تمت السيطره خلالها
على مدينه عفرين شمالي حلب وفي اكتوبر
تشرين الاول 2019 اطلق التركي عمليه النبع
السلام وجاء بعدها اتفاق سوتشي بين تركيا
وروسيا الذي نص على الاحتفاظ بالوضع
القائم وتحكم تركيا في عمق يقدر بنحو 30
كلم من الحدود شامله المدينه الابيض
راس العين
دكتور علي بكير اهلا وسهلا بك
الكل يتحدث الان عن هذه العمليه العسكريه
التركيه هل هي
واقعه فعلا لا محل حالها
اعتقد ان الجانب التركي يعني مصمم على
الاطلاق هذه العمليه البريه كل التصريحات
الرسميه الصادره عن رئاسه الجمهوريه
الناطق باسم رئيس الجمهوريه وزير الدفاع
وزير الخارجيه وغيرهم من المسؤولين عن
المستوى الميداني ايضا يشيرون الى استعداد
عسكري وسياسي لاطلاق هذه العمليه لكن
اعتقد ايضا بما ان الجانب التركي يريد ان
يعظم من مكاسبه وايضا يخفف قدر الامكان من
التكاليف التي قد تترتب على هذه العمليه
فهو يبحث عن امكانيه ايضا همم يعني همم
تسويات ربما تتيح له تنفيذ الاهداف دون ان
يطلق العمليه لكن الان طبعا هناك مساومات
حول هذه المواضيع لا تزال الامور المفتوحه
على كل الاحتمالات همم الجانب التركي ليس
لديه مصلحه في نهايه المطاف الاصطدام
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه داخل الشمال
السوري وايضا بروسيا ولذلك المفاوضات
اعتقد انها يعني البعض يربط ايضا همم هذه
العمليه باجواء انتخابيه تركيه داخليه وان
هذه العمليه ستكون على مراحل لجعل تاثير
هداخل الراي العام ايضا يستمر الى اي مدى
هذا صحيح انا رايي الشخصي انه اذا ما تم
اطلاق العمليه فعلا لن تكون على مراحل
يعني هم سيستهدفون المناطق الثلاثه الذي
قاموا بالتركيز عليها من خلال التصريحات
التي استمعناها اليها لكن هناك ايضا
حسابات تتعلق بمدى فعاليه هذه العمليه
لانه اذا حصل هناك حسابات خاطئه وارتفع
التكاليف العمليه فلذلك سيؤثر سلبا على
الحسابات الداخليه للانتخابات وهذا امر
غير محبه بالنسبه الى حزب العداله
والتنميه والرئيس التركي ولذلك انا اعتقد
ان الان وهم يبحثون عن افضل الامكانيه
لتنفيذ هذه العمليه دون ان يكون هناك
تكاليف عكس بشكل سلبي اذا طالت العمليه
على سبيل المثال او حصل هناك استنزاف او
قامت اطراف اقليميه او دوليه بالاستثمار
في رفع تكاليف هذه العمليه على الاجانب
التركي بس يكون هذا سيئا بالنسبه الى نظام
الحكم يعني المعارضه الامريكيه والتي نسال
عنها العقيد مايلز كاتينز من من نيويورك
الولايات المتحده اعربت على اكثر
من لسان مسؤول عن معارضتها الشديده لهذه
العمليه لماذا
ال 27 صباح الخير كما يقول باللغه العربيه
يسعدني ان انضم اليكم والى كل مشاهدي
الجزيره الاذكياء
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اليوم
قال فيها وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ليطلب منها ان ايقاف العمليات العسكريه في
سوريا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكما انتم
قلتم قبل قليل
تشارك مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لحاق
الهزيمه بدعش في سوريا وهذه الهجمات
التركيه قد سبب لحد الان
لايقاف قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه عملياتهم
العسكريه ضد تنظيم الدوله وان التحالف
الولايات المتحده وده استمرار هذه
العمليات لمنع تنظيم الدوله من العوده
هناك من يعتقد بان الخوف الامريكي الحقيقي
هو ان اي عمليه تركيه بريه ستغير من خريطه
السيطره الميدانيه وهناك قوات امريكيه قد
يتغير موقعها وهذا ما يقلق الولايات
المتحده اكثر
ياس نعم
في العراق
تركيا اطلقت عمليا داخل سوريا وان القوات
الامريكيه
غادرت غربي شمال سوريا
موجوده في
شرق وشمال الشرقي سوريا في محافظه الحسكه
ومحافظه دير الزور
في كل مره تدخل فيها القوات السوريه
العفوا التركيه الى سوريا فهناك مئات
الالاف من المدنيين الذين يظنون النزوح
والتحول الى لاجئين والكثيرون منهم يتوجون
الى منطقه كردستان العراق
يخافون من
قصر الجوي وهجمه والمدفعي من تركيا
[موسيقى]
تتهم قوات حمايه الشعب
وتعتقد بانه لا يمكن لها كتنظيم ارهابي
كما تسميه تركيا ان تحارب داعش كتنظيم
ارهابي اخر وهو ما تقوله الولايات المتحده
مثل ما استمعنا الى ضيفنا بالنسبه لقوات
حمايه الشعب ما الذي تخشاه حقيقه من عمليه
عسكريه تركيه محتمله
مساء الخير
للفهم حقيقه اللي كان ما يجري حاليا في
شمال سوريا
حدثت قبل الان يعني خلال عمليه عفرين التي
لم تكن تركيه لا تقدم عليها لولا حصولها
على الضوء اخضر امريكي
هو هذا ال- ال- ال- يعني النزوح الكبير
للسكان يعني هنالك تغيير كبير حدث في
منطقه عفرين تغيير سكاني كبير حدث في مع
بعض ايضا في منطقه راس العين اليكانيه
التي شاهدت عمليه عسكريه التركيه الثانيه
ايضا تمت بالتوافق وتركيا فقد وقعت امريكا
اتفاقا مع تركيا اتفاق المنطقه الامنه
وتحججت تركيا فيما بعد ان الاتفاق تمت
عرقلته لانه وحدات حمايه الشعب لم تسحب
اسهل اسلحتها الثقيله من المنطقه وقامت
بعد ذلك هجوم دعمته روسيه ايضا من خلال
القيام بدويات مشتركه مع تركيا بعمق 10
كيلومترات في المنطقه في تلك المنطقه ايضا
حدث سكانها كبير قدرته سائق الامم او سائق
الامم المتحده اكثر من 100,000 عاده عن
ذلكمقراطيه ايضا فقدت يعني فيها عفرين احد
همم ركائز وجودها يعني ارمونات تكون كرديه
سوريه تتكون من ثلاث اقاليم رئيسيه عندما
خسرت
عفري خسرت جزء كبير من مصادر تمويلها
ومصادر التجنيد وفي منطقه راس العين ايضا
عندما خسرت تلك المنطقه تم تقطيع واصل
المنطقه الكرديه السوريه بحيث اصبحت
كوباني في الغرب مع زوله عن القامشلي
والبلدات والمدن الاخرى في المنطقه الاخرى
اذا ما تخشوه وحدات حمايه الشعب والقائمين
عليها وصفه النتيجه حتى حسب العمال
الكردستاني
جيش الامريكي في السيطره عليها وبذلك يعني
لا يبقى اي مصدر شرعيه وجودهم في تركيا
سيد علي بكير تعتقد بان المشكله الرئيسيه
هي همم قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اساسا همم
قوات حمايه الشعب ولكن هذه القوات عملت
طوال الفتره الماضيه وتركيا لم تتحرك هذه
المره تتحرك بقوه وقوه اربكت الامريكيين
والروس في نفس الوقت كيف يمكن لها ان
تتجاوز هذا هذه المعارضه الروسيه ولا
امريكيه في نفس الوقت يعني انا اولا
الجانب التركي يرى ان هذه الميليشيات سواء
كانت قصد او وحدات حمايه الشعب هي تنظيمات
ارهابيه همم مرتبطه بالبيكيه الجانب
الامريكي على ذلك الجانب الروسي يعلم ذلك
وكل الناس تعلم هذا الامر همم الجانب
التركي يرى انه همم لا يجب ان يكون هناك
تصنيف ارهاب جيد وارهاب سيء كل الارهابيين
يجب مقاتلهم وبالتالي يجب على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان لا تتحالف مع هذه
تنظيمات خاصه ان هناك حليف استراتيجي ااه
عضو في النيته الجانب التركي قادر على
تنفيذ ما يقول الجانب الامريكي انه يخشى
منه وهو صعود داعش ايضا الاجانب التركي
يرى ان هناك الان موضوع داعش اصبح بمثابه
شماعه تستخدم لتغطيه التحالف الامريكي مع
وحدات حمايه الشعب وهمم
قوات ما يسمى بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وبالتالي الجانب التركي مصمم على دفع هذه
الميليشيات مسافه 30 كم وهذا الامر معلن
منذ سنوات وروسيا والاتحاد الامريكيه
تعليمات ذلك الان المعارضه الامريكيه
والمعارضه الروسيه من وجهه النظر التركيه
ليست حاسمه في منع عمليه عسكريه تركيه
بدليل ان الجانب التركي اطلق اربع عمليات
عسكريه حتى الان بالرغم من الاعتراض
الامريكي والروسي وكان هناك وعود من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا سيما في
العام 2019 زار نائب رئيس الولايات
المتحده في في ثاني يوم من الايام تركيا
وبعد سحب هؤلاء المقاتلين 20 كلم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بهذا الطلب الجانب
تركيا ان الظروف سامحه تماما بما ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا مشغوله
تان في اوكرانيا وايضا في مواجهه الصين
وايران ايضا مشهوره مشغوله باوضاعها
الداخليه هناك فرصه ثانيه الان همم المدير
قدما في مساله تحقيق المنطقه الامنه في
الداخل السوري الا تخشى انقره بتقديرك اي
احتكاك مع القوات الامريكيه لا يمكن
الحديث عن احتكاك مع القوات الروسيه ولكن
القوات الامريكيه وارد واشارت واشنطن الى
ان هذا يشكل ايضا تهديد لقواتها هناك لا
هو طبعا وارد مع القوات الامريكيه ومع
القوات الروسيه لان المناطق التي يريد
الجانب التركي ان يدخلها متواجد فيها نعم
وبالتالي هو يرى انه لا مصلحه لاحد
بالتصادم ولذلك الان يعطي فرصه قبل
اطلاقها للعمليه لهذه الاطراف التوصل الى
التفاهم بحيث ان العمليه لا تؤدي الى نزاع
او صدام مباشر بين الاجانب التركي والجانب
الامريكي والجانب التركي والجانب الروسي
ايضا لذلك الان المفاوضات جاريه في هذا
الشان بالتحديد يعني هناك نقطه مهمه همم
العقيد كنز الوجود الامريكي في تلك
المنطقه من شمال شرقي سوريا همم منطقه
ايضا فيها مصالح اقتصاديه فيها نفط فيها
غاز وهناك حديث بان الولايات المتحده لا
تريد ان تربك الانت الحالي لانها مستفيده
من الوضع الحالي واي عمليه عسكريه تركيا
قد تربك هذه الاستفاده الى اي مدى هذا
الرئيس صحيح
وتركي هذا تركيا
لديها تاريخ مثير في حربها ضد تنظيم
الدوله وخاصه في سوريا
2016 المدينه
و2000 من هؤلاء المقاتلين في تنظيم الدوله
هم المقاتلين الاجانب ومعظم هؤلاء
المقاتلين الاجانب دخلوا البلاد عن طريق
تركيا الى امراه ساحه معركه من العراق ومن
العراق ولا سوريا ولان قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تحت تجدهم وبالتالي فان موقف
التحالف الدولي هو منع تنظيم الدوله من
العوده
وان عمليات تركيا
الدوله
رئي هو ان واشنطن تعتبر حزب البيكي تنظيم
ارهابي ولكنها لا ترى ذلك بالنسبه لقوات
حمايه همم وحدات حمايه الشعب مع انها
امتداد لنفس الحزب وان موضوع محاربه تنظيم
داعش مثل ما قال ضيفنا هنا الدكتور علي
بكير اصبحت مجرد شماعه كيف يمكن لواء سنتم
ان
تفهم موقفها رغم هذا التحفظ
في الواقع ان النقطه الواضحه هي ان
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وهمم ووحدات حمايه الشعب التركي الكردي
عفوا داخل سوريا
يركزون على مساله قتال لتنظيم الدوله اااه
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في سوريا
استحتهم خفيفه وهم غير قادرون على مهاجمه
في اعماق الاراضي التركيه وهم هناك
احصاءات من همم حتى قدمها الباحثون تبين
بانه قبل 600 هجوم من تركيا على سوريا
فان القوات الكرديه ردت على عليها فقط
اربع مرات
والتالي نستطيع ان نرى من هو المعتدي هنا
وكذا ذلك نستطيع ان نرى ان تركيا لديها
ميزه تكنولوجيه باستخدام الطائرات مسيره
والطائرات المقاتله والمعدات العسكريه
المتطوره في حين انا قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تحاول مساعده العالم كله
ببقاء قوات مقاتله تنظيم الدوله في
الاعتقال ومنع تنظيم الدوله من العوده الى
دير الزور
الصحراء الباديه وفي على طول حوض نهر
الفرات في المقابل قوات حمايه الشعب السيد
حسين شلبي
تعتبر بان الموقف الامريكي ليس قويا بما
يكفي
وتنظر الى هذه المعارضه الامريكيه
والروسيه بعين غير مرتاحه هل تعتقد بان
قوات حمايه الشعب قادره على ان تراهن على
الموقف الامريكي والموقف الروسي لمنح حدوث
هذه العمليه المرتقبه
يعني مقوله وردت في احد اسئله اسئلتها وهي
نفاد هو ان تركيا راقبت الامور حتى وصلت
الى هذا المنحه فعلا تركيا هي منذ البدايه
جزء من تشكل هذا المشهد الحالي
فيتابعه تقاطر قواعد الحزب العمال
الكردستاني على المنطقه
السوريه وسكتت الى انما الحزب الى انت
قامت التجنيد الى انت حصل على التمويل
والى ان وصل المشهد الى حد اصطدام مع
تركيا قبل سنوات بالنسبه الوحدات حمايه
الشعب انا اتصور انها همم تعرف يعني لها
خبره مع الامريكيين يعني سبق وان تتخلى
عنها الامريكيون لكل بساطه فيها عفرين وفي
راس العين سيري
ووجوده حاليا خاصه
كريم في الاستديو بان همم استخدام سماعه
سماعه داعش همم هذه لا تستخدم حاليا في
غرب الفرات فشرقي الفرات هي التي تحوي
مراكز احتجاز عناصر تنظيم داعش وذويهم اما
غرب الفرات فلا يمكن لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ان تراهن على الامريكيين
والاران عليهم اصلا قبل ذلك خاصه
التي تتواجد فيها قواتهم وحصل يعني
تهديدات تركيا تطال منطقه غربي الفرات
وحدات حمايه الشعب ليست لديها القدره على
مقاومه الجيش التركي وهو الجيش ينتمي الى
حلف الناته ولديه اسلحه حديثه كما ذكرتهم
وحقيقه وحدات حمايه الشعب وحقيقه
التنظيمات العسكريه لحزب العمال
الكردستاني كرديا كثيرا ما ذكره ضيفكم
ايضا من من واشنطن انه هؤلاء حاربوا
العالم يعني هربوا داعش بدل العالم في هذه
الجزئيه هؤلاء يلامونه
دون ان يحصلوا على شيء يعني
تهتم تاجير كثير من السكان على خلفيه
التجنيد الذي جرى ويجري التهذه السعد دون
ان تسقيط ضيع هذه القوات ان تحقق اي شيء
على الارض اسلحتها خفيفه وتجاربها السابقه
سواء فيها عفرين او في راس العين سري كانه
تقول بانها ليست عصير على الهزيمه يعني
قصف التركي الذي يجري حاليا على موقعها او
على حول البلدات يحقق اهداف كبيره جدا
وهذه الوحدات عاجزه عن الرد على
الامريكيين
في النهايه يا دكتور علي بكير ما الذي
يمكن ان يرضي تركيا حتى لا تقوم بمثل هذه
العمليه يعني الجانب التركي كان واضح في
مطالب سواء لروسيا او الاتحاد الامريكيه
وخاصه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هم خلال
العام 2019 جرى طرح عرض يقوم على ثلاثه
تطبيقات رئيسيه اولا دفع الملكات المسلحه
هذه مسافه 30 كيلو متر لانها تشكل خطر على
الامن القومي التركي وعلى مواطنين اتراك
والسبق وان ارسل انتحاريين في العام 2016
و2017 كان هناك مئات الهجمات داخل تركيا
همم وادت الى اكثر من 1000 ضحيه همم
المطلب الثاني هو التسليم قاد في الفك
الكريم معروفين بالاسماء والاشكال ضمن
هيكل همم قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعرف هذا
الامر هذا لا يقتصر على الجانب تركيا ان
هناك تصريحات لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق همم هاشتن كارتر في همم جلسه
استماع رسميا امام همم لجنه الشؤون
قال في العام 2016 ان الواي بي جي هو جزء
من البيكيه ونفس الشيء الجنرال همم توماس
همم رونالدو اعتقد هو قال في العام 2017
انا طلبنا من نوكيا للبراندنج تغيير الاسم
وايضا ادخال بعض العناصر العربيه حتى لا
يقال ان امريكا متحالفه مع الارهاب اذا
هذا الامر معروف المطلب الثاني هو تسليم
هؤلاء المطلب الثالث هو السحب الاسلحه
الثقيله التي اعطيت لهذه التنظيمات هو هي
بالاطنان منذ العام 2015 لان هذه المشهد
تستخدمها في الهجوم على القوات التركيه
التي هي حليفه الامريكيه في حلف الناته
وايضا ضد المواطنين الاتراك والمناطق التي
تم تحريرها والاكراد المخالفين لايضا همم
مجموعات قصد ووحدات حمايه الشعب وهذه طبعا
ثلاث مطالب الى الان الجانب الامريكي لم
يقوم بتلتها همم طالما ان المعضله بالاساس
في هذه المساله الكرديه همم هناك تحفظ
يساق احيانا همم على تركيا هو انها مع مع
بدايه الثوره احت المجلس الوطني الكردي
ولكنها لم تقدم له الدعم الكافي مما ساهم
في بروز اطراف اخرى مثل همم وحدات حمايه
الشعب وغيرها في حين ان المجلس الوطني
الكردي لم يلقى اي دعم ومرفوض حتى من
وحدات الشعب
وحاربته لماذا لم تستطيع تركيا ان تؤمن
مجموعه كرديه تستطيع ان تتفاهم معه شوف هو
في بدايه الازمه السوريه الجانب التركي لم
يكن لديه خبره في داخل الصدر علينا ان لا
ننسى هذا يعني العلاقه التركيه العربيه
علاقه مستجده منذ العام على الاقل 2007
الى العام 2011 هذا لا يكفي لكي يكون
الجانب التركي معرفه وحصلت هناك اخطاء
بالفعل لكن ايضا كلامك هو دليل على انه لا
يوجد فريق واحد يمثل الاكراد هناك همم
اكراد يدعمونا المعارض السوريه هناك ايضا
اكراد همم يعني ضمن الفصائل الجيش السوري
الحر وبالمناسبه الجيش السوري الحر هو اول
من قاتل تنظيم داعش وتنظيم القاعده ونظام
الاسد والجانب الايراني والتدخل الروسي
ومع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قامت بغض
النظر عن المجازر التي ارتكبت بحقه من قبل
النظام الاسد وايضا لدينا تنظيم القاعده
والجنرال ديفيد باتريوس في العام 2015
اقترح على الجانب الامريكي ان يتم
الاستعانه بالقاعده لمحاربه داعش اذا هذه
الموضوع همم قوات خاصه ومحدات حمايه الشعب
هي شماعه لتبرير التواجد الامريكي داخل
سوريا لانه من من دون هذا الوصله لا يمكن
الجانب الامريكي البقاء داخل سوريا هذا
الامر هو امر سياسي الجانب التركي يقول لي
الاكراد ول- اا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انه بالامكان الاعتماد علي
لتامين الاستقرار في المنطقه واعاده
اللاجئين ومحاربه داعش اذا ما كان هناك
حاجه لذلك لكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لدي حسباتها الاخرى مختلفه هذه الحسابات
الامريكيه همم
الجنس كيف يمكن لها ان توظفها في تفاهم ما
مع مع انقره لمنع همم هذه العمليه لان
واشنطن كما تقول تتفهم المخاوف الامنيه
لتركيا ولكنها لا تشاطرها في الذهاب الى
حد هذه العمليه البريه اذا كيف يمكن لها
ان ترضي واشنطن انقره
الامريكيه حاولت ان
تتجاوب مع الطلب التركي منذ بدايه القتال
ضد تنظيم الدوله في عام 2015 الولايات
المتحده
قدمت تقريبا 200 مليون دولار من المعدات
العسكريه كمساعدات لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وان كل الاسلحه الامريكيه
والذخائر الامريكيه التي قدمت لقوات
الديمقراطيه ذكرت في تقارير بشكل شفاف
وقدمت الى انقر في عام 2019
العمليات الامريكيه الخاصه التعاون مع
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لاجراء وتنظيف
منطقه 30 كلم
ولكن تركيا لم ترى ابدا ولا ترضى نعلم ان
تركيا ستواصل لهجمه تركيا لانهم قالوا انه
ميعادلون ذلك ان تركيا وايران وقاد الروس
التقوا في طهران قبل بضعه اشهر من الواضح
ان ايران
ستهاجم الاكراد في كردستان العراق وتركيا
ستهاجم الاكراد في سوريا وفي كردستان
العراق وروسيا تريد من الولايات المتحده
ان تخرج من سوريا
يحاولون الدفع الولايات المتحده بعيدا
واخراجها
وكثر العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده وقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه
الان بالضبط
اكثر قدره على التفاهم عن قرار هذه
الحسابات التي تشير اليها الان
تركي التركي تقوم بعمليات عسكريه ضد
الميليشيات الكرديه منذ سنوات طويله وانا
اعتقد حسب رايي الشخصي كمحلل
بان تركيا ستواصل هذه العمليات وان القوات
الامريكيه تقف في طريقها تقف في طريق طموح
التركي الذي شرحه بشكل واضح الرئيس
اردوغان
بانكز منطقه طولها 30 كيلو متر وصولا الى
شمال تركيا من اللاذقيه الى دركور
وربما تلك المنطقه
ستستمر
كردستان العراق لا نستطيع ان نتوقع
المستقبل واتنبئ به ولكن
الان اهم شيء هو ان الضربات الجويه
والضربات وقذف المدفعي لابد ان يتوقفوا
لذلك لتمكين
الشعب الموجود في شمال شرقي سوريا
للتمتعوا بالسلام ولا تستطيع قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه الابقاء على تركيزها لمكافحه
المحافظه على القيام بعمليات ضد تنظيم
الدوله اذا تعذر
تفاهم تركي امريكي لمنع العمليه السيد
حسين شلبي هل يمكن ان نتوقع تفاهم تركي
روسي من نوع اخر
الغاء هذه العمليه او تاجيلها على الاقل
حقيقه انا لا اعلم على ماذا ستفهم الاتراك
مع مع الامريكيين في الامريكيين هم بمنئه
عما يجري صحي هم يتحدثون في الاعلام شيء
ولكنهم يفعلون عكسه ان المنطقه التي
تتواجد فيها امريكا يعني تتمتع بالحصانه
عن حسب التصريحات حتى التركيه يعني اتراك
لا يقولون انهم سيهاجمون شرقين فرات على
المقلب الاخر اذا توجهنا نحو
التفاعل الروسي التركي المحتمل نجد بانها
هاتين الدولتين يعني وتوصلتها او تتقاطع
مصالحهما مع بقاء نظام الاسد في الحكم
وتركيا لم تخفي الفتره الاخيره همم رغبتها
في تسليم تلك المناطق التي المناطق
الثلاثه التي تحدثت عنها كوباني
في عوده نظام الاسد الى تلك مناطق اذا
التفاهم هو موجود اتفاق هو موجود يعني بس
هي لا يهما من كل ما يجري سوا ااا يعني
بقاء نظام الاسد وهو قد بقي ااا يعني يبدو
ابنه سيستمر لكن تركيا تبدو بالنسبه كما
انا ارى انها معنيه اكثر بالسكان يعني
مشكله تركيا لا اتوقع انها كثيره هي يعني
مع وحدات الشعر او قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
التي كما هو واضح كما تابعنا خلال سنوات
الماضيه لم تكن هنالك هجمات
على جانب تركيا تريد ان يعني تخلق وضع
مشابه وضع عفرين هي الصيد التامين
والجائزه الكبرى بالنسبه لها هي منطقه
كوباني
ومشكلته هي مع التغيير السكاني وليس مع
قوات خاصه التي يمكنها مره اخرى يمكن
افرادها مره اخرى ان يحمل اسلحتهم ويغادر
المنطقه سواء تحت عنوان هزيمه او عنوان
انسحب
شرط هنا الى همم النظام في في دمشق هل
تعتقد بان اي تفاهم تركي روسي من سيستفيد
منه في المقام الاول هو النظام الذي سيعود
الى هذه المناطق التي تخشاها تركيا وتخشى
ان تنطلق منها عمليات ارهابيه كما تسميها
هو النظام الاسد يعني عاد الى المنطقه همم
بعد عمليه راس العين سريه او التي اسمتها
تركيا عمليه نبع السلام في ذلك الوقت كان
ذلك تفاهمات بين الجميع بين تركيا وروسيا
وامريكا على عوده نظام الاسد الى المنطقه
شاهدنا نحن همم عوده وحدات من الجيش
السوري دخلت مدن عاموده وحتى منطقه مدينه
كوباني
همم الذي يربط كوباني مع تركيا يعني
النظام يرفع علامه حاليا ومخاطر نظام
الاثر فعلا هي موجوده وحدات حمايه الشعر
هو وجود شكري فعلا نظام الاسد هو المستفيد
الاكبر مما يجري
والجميع الحج اليه يعني هو على ضعفه هو
يبدو بان الجميع يحتاج اليه لذلك
تركيا تسعى الى رضاه سبب الحسابات
انتخابيه او الى اخره المعادله التركيه 9
وقوات اسد يعني تستعين به او يحاول ان
تستعيد ايضا اسد ولكن النظام يبقى بنفس
قائد قصد ان انا مؤخرا لانه لا يستطيع
الاعتماد على سلاح الجو
ولكن هو يرفع السقف مع تركيا يريد ان يحصل
على همم يعني منافع على صالح في اذنه وكل
ما يجرح حقيقه هو رساله الى المعارض
السوريه
وتتقدم صفوف الجيش التركي هي عمليه محتمله
مناطق الثلاث التي تم ذكر عده مرات هذه
اذا سالنا بالنسبه لموقف تركيا هنا اسمحلي
اعود الى الدكتور بكير بالنسبه لتركيا اذا
خيرت بين تفاهم مع امريكا لمنع هذه
العمليه او تفاهم مع روسيا
ما هو الاقرب اليها هو الجانب التركي يسعى
الى تحقيق مصالحه الخاصه اذا قادر ان يجمع
بين الامرين بين بين الاتصالات وتفاهمات
امريكيه وروسيا في نفس الوقت لكن السؤال
هل سيقدم الجان الامريكي او الروسي ما همم
يعني يرضي الجانب التركي في هذا السياق
انا حتى الان لا اعتقد ذلك لانه الجانب
الامريكي ليس لديه ما يقدمه على ما يبدوه
اولا ثانيا هذه الاشياء التي تحدثنا عنها
قصه يعني هي ليست فقط حديثه علاقتها
ممتازه مع النظام السوري بدليل الضيف تكلم
بشكل صحيح عن تواجد نظام سوري في نقاط
مشترك معها لديها علاقات قويه مع همم
الحرس الثوري وفي شهر سبعه الماضي تم
انشاء غرف عمليات مشتركه مع النظام
الايراني
التالي هي ايضا تستخدم كورقه الجانب
الروسي ي- يضغط منذ العام 2017 على تركيا
لكي يقول انه بامكان حصول تفاهم نستطيع من
خلاله ان نجبر هذه البلاشات على الانسحاب
لكن على تركيا ان تقبل بتواجد للنظام
السوري هذا الفراغ وان تفعل اتفاق قدنا
لكن الجانب التركي لا يقبل حتى الان هذه
المعادله بدليل ان اا انه يعتقد ان النظام
السوري هو السبب الاساسي في تواجد هذه
يعني يعني لحد ما متفاهم الى هذه النقطه
يعني بمعنى انه اولا اشار قبل الفتره بان
هناك تعاون مع النظام في محاربه الارهاب
كما سماه واا مستعد بشكل من الاشكال الى
فتح صفحه جديده معه مع النظام ربما ربما
همم وهنا المفارقه انهم مستعد ان يعطي هذه
المناطق يعطيها بين قوسين يعطي هذه
المناطق الى النظام
افضل من ان تضل عن عند قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وهنا هذه المفارقه المربكه
يعني لا انا لا اعتقد ذلك نعم الجانب
التركي مؤخرا اذا ما نتابعنا يرسل رسائل
لكن هذه الرسائل المخصوص الاسد موجهه الى
روسيا وليس الى نظام الاسد هو يقول انه
منفتح لكن اذا حصل تحول في موقف النظام
السوري بمعنى ان هناك مطالب من النظام
السوري اهمها محاربه هذه الاشيات ثانيا
همم
تسليم ايضا المطلوبين وثا اجراء تعديل همم
في العمليه السياسيه لم يحصل اي تقدم
بخصوص الاتفاقات التي جرت حتى الان في
الملف السوري واخيرا السماح للاجئين
بالعوده دون التحديد وحتى الان لا اعتقد
ان النظام السوري سيلبي اي من هذه الشروط
وهو غير قادر حتى لو دخل الى هذا المناطق
ان يضمن فعليا امن هذه المناطق لان ليس
لديه قدره عسكريه على الارض على التمدد
بهذا الشكل وممكن حينها ان يعود باستخدام
هذه من الارشاد ضد الجانب التركي في اي
وقت لذلك اجانب تركيا
حتى الان لا يوجد هناك امر حسن في هذا همم
نريد ان نقوم في نهايه همم هذه الحلقه
كالعاده بجوله بين ضيوفنا الثلاثه
لمعرفه بين امكانيه قيام العمليه وبين
امكانيه التراجع عنها في ضوء تفاهمات
معينه سواء مع واشنطن او مع روسيا نبدا
بالعقيد بميلز همم السيناريو الذي ترجحوا
في ضوء ما كنا نت عنه منذ بدايه هذه
الحلقه
احتمال هو التكرار للتاريخ الحديث الذي
حصل في شمال شرقي سوريا فبعد عفرين دفع
تركيا
الناس الذين سيعانون ان اولئك الموجودون
في شمال شرقي سوريا من الاكراد والعرب
والمسيحيين
والهولاهم
سيعانين تدخل فيها تركيا
من كانت ترفع الصوت عاليا لكن عندما تشرع
تركيا في فرد الامر على الارض همم تقبل
واشنطن بالامور كما هي
نعم
نموذج
الى التصعيد ولكن فقط في الاسبوع الماضي
في العراق
من النت ومن الولايات المتحده حسين شلبي
ماذا ترجح
خنقت تركيا من خلال الضغط الاعلامي في
الحديث عن خطر حزب العمال الكردستاني
مؤخرا ومن خلال عمليات القصف التي
تقوم بها عبر الحدود واقعا يصعب عليها
تراجع عنه انا اتوقع كما اشاره ضيفكم
الكريم
استمرار القصف الامريكي على المنطقه القصف
الجوي واستخدام السيارات لمده معينه
المقبله ولكن في لحظه ما عندما يكون ذلك
عندما تشعر تركيا بان امريكا عطتها الضوء
الاخضر
او من تحت الطاوله نتيجه فرض شروط معينه
او تلبيه شروط معينه اتوقع ان تكون هنالك
عمليه تركيه بريه محدوده لن تستطيعني لكن
انا لا استطيع حقيقه تحديد متى سيتم ذلك
ولكن الى ذلك الوقت سيستمر القصف سيتمر
سيستمر
تستمر ماساه السكان المدنيين مع الاسات
الشديد وال قوات سوريا الديكورات المسلحين
هم كما ذكرت دائما لمن اا بمنجى عما يجري
ممكن ان يتجنب بسهوله القسم التركي قد تقع
خسائر بني صوفهم ولكن الخاصه اكبر فيما
يجري هم المدنيون دكتور بكير انا اعتقد
الجانب التركي مصمم على اطلاق هذا العمليه
الان او بعد شهر او بعد سته اشهر ربما بعد
الانتخابات لكن في نهايه المطاف سيجري
هناك عمليه علينا ان لا ننسى ايضا ان
الجانب التركي يعاني تحت الضغط اللاجئين
هناك اكثر من 10 مليون سوري خارج سوريا
الان 4 مليون منهم في في تركيا وهؤلاء لا
تتحمل طبعا همم طبيعتهم وادوات المتحده
الامريكيه او روسيا او غير عامر البلدان
هناك الضغوط حقيقيه على الجانب التركي في
هذا المجال انا اعتقد انه الان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قادره فعليا على ايقاف
تركيا ان هي صممت الدخول ولا روسيا ايضا
وفي نفس الوقت الجانب تركي ليس لديه مصلحه
في الاصطدام مع امريكا والاستضدام مع لذلك
يحاول تدليل العقبات امام اي عمليه عسكريه
في نهايه المطاف التواجد الامريكي صغير في
سوريا واعتقد انه الجانب الامريكي بحاجه
الى تركي الان فيما يتعلق بالوضع في
اوكرانيا نفس الشيء فيما يتعلق بروسيا
ربما يغض الطرفان ال- ال- ال- اللاعبان
الطرف عن اي عمليه عسكريه قادمه لكن في
نهايه المطاف اجانب التركي اعتقد انه
سيطلق هذا العمليه عاجلا
لهجه التحدي والاصرار لدى القياده التركيه
عاليه جدا بمعنى انه اي امكانيه للتراجع
ستبدو وكانها تنازل في هذه الحاله ما
العمل صحيح لكن انا شخصيا لا يعني ليس
هناك مجال للتراجع الجانب التركي لديه خطه
هذه خطه منذ العام 2013 وهذه خطه لديها
مبرراته يعني شاهدنا الشهر الماضي عمليه
ارهابيه في السوق الشعبي في تركيا ال- ال-
المنفذه العمليه جاءت من مناطق تحت سيطره
هذه الاشياء وبالتالي جانب التركي صار في
موضوع انشاء المنطقه الامنه الا ان يتم
ايجاد حل سياسي لسوريا وهو يرى انه تامين
هذه المنطقه تخدم في نهايه المطاف استقرار
سوريا ووحده الاراضي السوريه يعني علينا
ان ننسى ان هذه الميشيات تريد ايضا اقتطاع
الشمال السوري لانشاء دوله وهذا امر غير
ممكن قبول بالنسبه للجان التركي العلاقه
التركيه مع روسيا قويه جدا خاصه في الملف
الاوكراني والرئيس اردوغان لا يمكن ان
يجاذب بخساره بوتين في في هذا الموضوع هو
اللاعب دور الوسيط وهمزه الوصل بين الحلف
الاطلسي وروسيا في هذه الحلقه اذا اراد ان
يرضي روسيا دون ان يتراجع كثيرا ما الذي
عليها ان يفعل انا اعتقد ان العلاقه
التركيه روسيه قويه هي علاقه معقده يعني
الجانب التركي اوقف التمدد الروسي في
سوريا في شمال افريقيا في ليبيا في همم
القوقاز في اذربيجان وفي غيرها من المناطق
وبالتالي علاقه معقده ايضا هو دعم
اوكرانيا عسكريه وبالمسيرات والى اخره لكن
انا اعتقد ان هناك مساحه الان للجانب
التركي او هكذا يعتقد الجانب التركي انا
مساحته للتحرك الان في مواجهه روسيا او
امريكا وان روسيا الى تركيا الان اقتصاديا
او سياسيا حاجه اكبر من حاجه الجانب
التركي وفي نهايه المطاف التطورات الاوضاع
في سوريا تعني تركيا مباشره وليس الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على الاف التي تقع يعني
بعيده الافكلمات ولا ايضا على الجانب
السوري
واعتقد ان الجانب تركي يفكر من هذه
الزاويه في هذا الوضع بالتحديد شكرا جزيلا
لك دكتور علي بكير الخبير في شان التركي
شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من همبرج حسين شلبي
الكاتب والباحث في الشان الكردي شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من نيويورك العقيد مايل سكنز كبير
الباحثين في معهد نيولاينز للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه وشكرا لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام على حسن المتابعه دمتم في
رعايه الله ونلتقي الخبيث المقبل باذن
الله في متابعات همم سياسيه جديده وسميرات
جديده رغم كل الاهتمام بكاس العالم وما
يجري في كاس العالم في امان الله
[موسيقى]